so sweet
[Music]
hey there
this is my motorcycle
a lot of you have been asking me about
what it's like riding in los angeles and
i figured with spring right around the
corner now would be the perfect time to
talk about a few of the tips and tricks
i've learned over the last few years of
riding that way if you're interested
or even just a little bit of perspective
on what it's like out there on two
wheels instead of four
check this out
for those of you who have never been on
two wheels of any kind before consider
this fun fact first do you know how to
ride a bicycle
if the answer is no i would suggest
getting a bicycle you can get one online
for 125
pretty good one and you might find you
get a lot more exercise you learn how to
balance better and those shops that you
thought were farther away are closer
than you think
okay so you know how to ride a bicycle
the next question is how do i get a
license to ride a motorcycle well it's
pretty simple you need to pass a written
test
and you need to pass
a driving test
there are two ways to pass the driving
test at least in the state of california
and it's probably true for other states
number one you can go to the dmv and
just take a cold driving test i think
you need to be over the age of 18 or
something like that but the dmv website
will tell you number two which i highly
recommend taking a motorcycle education
course this will teach you the basics of
not only how to ride but once you pass
the course you'll have successfully
passed the driving test and it also will
lower your insurance
there are a bunch of different places
where you can take your driving test i
did mine for example at the
harley-davidson of glendale basically i
paid him 200 bucks and i spent the
weekend riding motorcycles and having
fun with my friends and at the end of it
i knew how to ride a motorcycle but
don't forget you have to take your
written test at the dmv it's like a 40
question piece of paper don't worry if
you fail you can always take it again
it's not the bar exam
you see this 90s nurse style
corridor digital t-shirt that i got
right here
it's available for the last day and the
last day only in the quarter digital
store right now it'll be gone forever
tomorrow get it
get it now but seriously
today's the last day to get them i hope
you guys like them we're gonna have more
cool limited edition shirts later but
they'll never be like this again
no sir
great so you've now obtained your
motorcycle license congratulations
prepare to have the most fun you're
about to have on two wheels the next
question is naturally decide which kind
of bike you want there's sport bikes
cafe racers cruisers there's custom
bikes
do a little research and find out which
ones you like
as you can see here i prefer
harley-davidson's specifically the
dynastreet bobs are kind of my go-to i
started on some smaller bikes and worked
my way up to these ones i've custom this
one out a little bit to give it a club
style it's a lot of fun for me gives me
performance keeps me off the ground
a lot of stability
and it's fast as heck at the end of the
day it doesn't really matter which type
of bike you go with just make sure that
it's an extension of your personality
and have some fun with it i love
harley's because you can customize the
heck out of them you can pretty much do
whatever you want to them
and this one's mine bikes are an
investment so start small keep it simple
you're going to spend a lot of money
just on your bike up front so make sure
that you do your research and that you
plan on growing your motorcycle
experience this is my third motorcycle
and over time i grew not only in the
engine size but also in the performance
and in the style and i as i learned more
and more about what i wanted because
over time you want to customize your
bike you want to customize your gear you
put more and more time and energy into
it to find out what works exactly for
you start small and grow slowly over
time this isn't some cheap date that you
took to a drive-in movie theater that
doesn't exist anymore
this is a relationship depending on what
you want to get out of your bike you're
going to want to learn a little bit
about how to take it apart and put it
back together like any good relationship
it requires work learn a little bit
don't be afraid to take parts off put
them back on buy some new tools and
learn a little bit about the mechanics
of how it works every bike is different
every bike has its own ticks and hums
and sounds and you'll know once you're
riding which ones are right and which
ones are wrong the more mechanical
ability you have the easier it'll be to
maintain your bike to keep it up and
have fun while riding like any skill
worth keeping in life it's honed over
time slowly and surely you don't learn
how to ride like a pro in a single day
it's about spending hours on the bike
it's a craft it's a skill it's a mindset
as you go along
respect your machine if you don't it
could kill you
first take first try arrow through the
gaff tape
[Applause]
hey nick you know what else is an
ultimate first take bruce try what
getting a tattoo that's actually true
yeah me and my brother got it done up in
seattle at this place called super
genius tattoo did you guys both get the
same tattoo we both did yes
uh nice always you get the same tattoos
you always i wanted my brothers to get
this one it's my family crest right here
but they both whisked out on me my my
brother quinn was like yeah dude i'll
totally get it and then i got it and i
was like all right what is that like a
little
and he didn't get a tree it's a oak tree
on a knoll with a blue chevron and two
stars the oak tree stands for fertility
and strength and the blue chevron is for
the native land of scotland the stars
are because i'm the third son of my
father i've got a griffin up top
just like the top of the family crest
and then down here i've got an eagle
and two lions one here
and one here because an eagle and a lion
make a
brett you just got a tattoo too right i
did son right before the new year i did
nice um what prompted you to get it uh
basically just this this whole past year
like the the the prior year was a
kind of a
journey it's a journey for sure you
wanted to mark and remember that journey
i did definitely that's great that's a
great reason to get a tattoo there's a
lot of reasons why people get tattoos
but that's a great one it's a sparrow
and it's uh there's a phrase on it
that's meant a lot to me over the years
since this too shall pass could you tell
me son who's tattoo is that whose tattoo
is it's mine tattoos and it's on my arm
son oh [ __ ]
three four five six seven eight nine ten
well you might have to establish the
rules of the game of life for this
episode because brett just got got
red's got a tattoo but i don't know
where he went i do have a tattoo what is
that what we're doing yeah you want to
tattoo it yeah all right tell us what
inspired you to get it
and when did you get it
uh you've never asked yourself that you
ever asked why am i getting a tattoo
right now
no that's
[Laughter]
[Applause]
how to say it anymore it's hard to see
it's hard to read
even looking in the mirror it's all
backwards quote actually says is all we
have to decide is what to do with the
time that has given us it's a quote from
lord of the rings
all we have to decide is what to do with
the time that is given to us that is the
actual quote in the book whose shirt is
that
this is my shirt
living on the edge
man
i got one more tattoo recently
i'm actually the most proud of this out
of any of the other ones that i have
it's our patrons come on you guys first
of all i'd like to thank andrew ryan
calvin kingdom
john welch
sohak lai aka so-so his hero
ahmed el-zabi james bailey and of course
richard blackburn thank you guys
so much
for supporting us it means the world to
us if you consider supporting us on
patreon you can check it out at
patreon.com backslash corridor digital
we've got a lot of cool rewards and if
you would like your name on my arm
consider
supporting
what you asked me is this a sponsored
video
no it's not i just really like writing
and i get a lot of questions about it
and figured you guys might find this
information useful
that's it
put on a serious note
get a harley
[Applause]
ah
[Music]
[Music]
did
[Music]
hey ren
i'm hiring you as my camera guy
[Music]
guys i won but not really i got shot
like five times when i walked through
the door but this is a tactical vest it
can take up to five bullets without me
dying
we did it
dude right as i walked through the door
you shot one and just hit me in the face
like headshot yeah
this ammo is so tactical
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i have a tactical vest on
i got the other guys pretty good though
just hoping you're in vr if you didn't
know already today is the last day to
buy this sweet 90s nerf style corridor
digital t-shirt get it now it's the last
day it'll never be available again and
if you don't get it
where are you gonna put your gopros
not here
no way no way jose
not happening
links are in the description
do below make your killings clean slugs